[Music]
from Disney comes the last film in this
X universe to remind us that just like
the human body when a franchise dies it
craps itself dark Phoenix
roll the dice on the latest x-men joint
and IP that's given us the highest highs
the lowest lows and the midlist mids to
revisit the Dark Phoenix storyline from
x-men 3 only this time we really get to
know Jean Grey no not really okay but
we're exploring the cosmic potential of
the Phoenix force no after the intro
it's on earth okay fine we'll finally
see what a new creative team can do with
this material no sane guy who wrote
x-men last hand but now he's directing -
you know what they say fool me once
shame on you fool me twice and you could
probably fool me again
because I like the cartoon and nerds are
easy marks previously on x-men just
kidding
doesn't matter because no one will
explain how or why magneto is a free man
after the last movie or how the x-men
have a hard line to the president after
this happened or why they keep skipping
decades even though it puts these
characters in their 50s now 50s but
whatever pretend this is the first one
you've seen and thrill as Jean Grey
fights an evil space cloud
a monotone space alien if we can control
that power we can resurrect our race
begin again and a consistent American
accent I don't have a home you made sure
that in a story that banks on you caring
about a character who's barely on the
screen before this it's almost like
focusing on mystique for the last three
movies was now hear me out a bad choice
mutant and proud audience and over it
see the court x-men how you've come to
expect them by now annoyed bored as
always a speech and nobody chasm and way
too famous to sit for makeup but they'll
step aside to give the New Mutants
something to do or rather these mutants
like Cyclops who's random f-bomb in a
pg-13 movie is the closest he comes to a
personality if you touch her I will
[ __ ] kill you Quicksilver who's once
again sideline before his powers make
everyone else pointless Nightcrawler
who's gone from thriller fan to killer
man
and storm who's been so conditioned to
have nothing to do that she lets it pour
rain at a Funeral
ah now the whole mansion is gonna smell
like a wet dog
gross ever wonder what it would look
like if you got to make the next x-men
probably something like this because
this is the directors first movie and
he's spending two hundred million
dollars on his student film showing off
exactly how superhero actors look if
it's not handled with care and expertise
morons they look like absolute morons
okay pretend you're trying to open a jar
with your mind
so press X to pay respects to the final
terrible movie of the current x-men
franchise that you could play on the
writer/director failing upwards or
last-minute reshoots to make it less
like Captain Marvel or the main cast
wishing they were dead
now the only ones left or you could
choose to remember all the good times
forget this ever happened and then try
reading some x-men comics instead did
you know they made books out of all
these movies there's even pictures
inside starring Lady Bird Charlie in the
child soldier Factory
let's see them aliens all magneto had a
farm x-men origins Fraser quoth the
Raven please no more taser face gotta go
fast Jake Gyllenhaal I'm not here to
make friends and the MCU stealing the
x-men oh I get it
x-men 4x3 take to the last one gene did
not have this much blood on her where
she flew away whose blood is this whose
blood is it gene did you kill Cyclops
off screen again me think why waste time
say lot word when few word do trick I'm
not crazy I'm cuckoo for cocoa puffs
Prince all the fabulous he Ali Ababwa
Doug dimmadome owner of the dimmsdale
dimmadome you need to speak up I am
wearing a towel